l'église baptiste du plateau-mont-royal
ponder en 2012 par le pasteur bradley
maurice loue un local à l'école
secondaire jeanne mance depuis le 27
septembre dernier
ils y tiennent leur messe dominicale
mais le groupe compte s'impliquer
davantage fait que ça fait quelques
semaines j'ai eu une rencontre avec
l'adresse puis j'ai pu lui poser la
question comment est ce qu'on peut vous
aider à des surprises mais très très
contente fait qu'elle m'a donné une
liste de quatre choses qu'on pourrait
faire pour elle puis celle qui était la
plus frappante c'est le fait justement
qui ont fermé la bibliothèque
les élèves n'ont plus accès à la
bibliothèque à l'extérieur des heures de
classe
plusieurs membres du groupe religieux
nous ont confirmé être en formation
technique afin de pouvoir y travailler
la liste de besoins énumérés par la
direction de l'école comprendrait aussi
l'aide aux devoirs et le rajeunissement
de l'équipement musicale selon la
commission scolaire de montréal
aucune décision n'a encore été prise
mais elle confirme qu'une étude
d'antécédents judiciaires pour leur
permettre d'y travailler est en cours le
fait qu'on soit dans une école zappé
certains questionnements même des labos
réserve là pour des professions a
probablement la dre crise nous ouvre ses
portes
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on est là
pourraient commencer à les évangiles
nous autres la division balises du
plateau on dit qu'on veut prendre corps
un renouveau spirituel culturel et
social
mais cette initiative soulève aussi
beaucoup de questions
selon ge lefebvre a suivi de près
l'évolution de la relation entre les
écoles et la religion sans se prononcer
sur le cas de l'école secondaire jeanne
mance en particulier elle est d'avis que
les règles doivent être claires on sait
très bien que les éditeurs repose
beaucoup sur les bénévoles pour
compléter ce que les taux ne peut pas
faire mais si ça se fait dans une école
ou encore une fois se trouvent des
personnes mineures
évidemment il faut établir des règles
claires il ne faut pas que ça devienne
une occasion de prosélytisme
la location de locaux groupes religieux
à l'extérieur des heures de classe est
permise mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
contacts directs entre un groupe
religieux et des élèves
comment s'assurer que les intentions
respecte le principe de neutralité dans
nos écoles on s'en va dans son ensemble
vos aïeuls pour montrer pour aimer les
gens pour les aider pour donner notre
temps pour leur montrer le nom de jésus
puis je trouve ce fou que dieu nous
utilisent si on ne voit rien que du
transformer vie comme je les construis
nous dit mais ça va se ressentir les
gens vont faire non
il ya comme quelque chose qui combat qui
savait que l'occasion ne pas leur dire
les zelda rendu on n'est pas là pour
évangéliser on est là pour aider si
quelques me pose la question pourquoi
est ce que tu est ici ses joueurs
sûrement glissé un mot que c'est jésus
qui qui dit de chercher le bien-être de
mon quartier mais mon prochain s'ils
voudraient en parler plus ils répètent
une autre maman pour ça mais faut faire
attention avec ça peu d'étudiants sont
au courant que le groupe religieux vient
de s'installer à l'école christophe
étudiants l'école jeanne mance a été
engagé comme technicien lors des messes
du dimanche qui se tiennent à
l'auditorium de son école dans la
famille pour le moment ça fait un peu
bizarre c'est ma famille est très
catholique mais
bon c'est que c'est
je dis ça change rien la présidente de
la commission scolaire de montréal
réagit on prend en compte les personnes
qui nous offre des services de bénévolat
et ces personnes là peuvent être de
toutes origines de toutes religions de
tous secteurs de tous quartiers de la
ville ce sont des citoyens et on regarde
lord aussi qu' on regarde mon besoin
et